This is a common
problem that we see.
Some fancy language
has a dedicated guide
of best practices
that define how
the creators want developers to
use that particular language.
Now sometimes, this
is great advice
in order to create more
stable and robust code.
But all that safety
usually comes
at the cost of performance.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And the best
practices in Java say
that iterators are the ideal
way to walk over a collection.
But that's specifically
for language stability.
So are iterators
the best practice
when it comes to performance?
There's two main things you
need to know about iterators.
Firstly, know that every
time you get an iterator,
it will result in a
memory allocation.
Of course, one allocation is
not necessarily a big deal.
But when you're
grabbing iterators
from a number of lists, or
all inside of a parent loop,
or inside the onDraw function,
those extra allocations
are going to chew
through your memory heap.
And secondly, it's very
typical for iterators in Java
to do additional
computational checking.
For example, calling
the next function,
typically, will do a check
to see if the container has
been modified before
allowing you to step through
to the next item.
Under normal circumstances,
not really a big deal.
But remember.
You're incurring that overhead
for every single element
in your collection.
Oh, and you're also doing
this on a mobile device
as well, which means that these
are not light problems that you
can easily ignore for
the sake of convenience.
In fact, these
performance concerns
are large enough that
even the Android platform
team, the team who actually
writes the Android code,
has a general policy to
avoid using iterators
in any part of
their platform code.
But lets not give in to
rumors and hearsay here.
How bad is the problem, really?
Well, to figure that
out, let's run a test,
try a few different
ways to walk a list,
and see how iterators
stack up to other options.
OK.
So, our test should include,
bare minimum, an iterator
object to walk over
a list collection.
That's a given, since it's
what we're talking about here.
And just as a baseline example.
Let's also test
the most simple way
to walk a list using a for
loop alongside the get method
with a specific index.
And the Java 5 version
of the language
also defines a simplified syntax
for iterating any collection,
so that's also
worth testing just
to see if the reduced
syntax also comes along
with any weird performance
wins that we don't know about.
In fact, actually,
just to be safe,
let's make sure that we
test all of our comparisons
against using a Vector
and an ArrayList.
This should hopefully
give us a good set of data
that we can compare against to
get some additional insights.
Any test that's going
to discuss performance
usually needs some
listed explanation
of how the tests were
performed, under what
conditions, et
cetera, et cetera,
so that the numbers can all
be understood and reported
in a meaningful manner.
So that's what all
that gibberish is.
Anyhow, on to the
results at hand.
Bringing up the
bottom of our list
is the iterator and simple
for loop syntax on Vector
objects, specifically.
The next fastest algorithms
are the for simple and iterator
functions on ArrayLists,
which clock in at pretty
much the same time.
This is expected,
since, under the hood,
they both use relatively
the same code paths,
which of course means
that the winners
of our friendly competition
is the computer science 101
style for loop using an index
to grab the specific object.
And notice the
relative numbers here.
The for loop over an
ArrayList was almost 2x
faster than using an
iterator to accomplish
the same results, which
just goes to show you kids,
just because the language says
it's the right thing to do,
doesn't mean that it will always
give you the best performance.
But actually, I take that back.
What this really goes to show
you is that before you run off
and start making
changes to your code
based upon what you've
read on the internet
or heard from friends, always
verify your assumptions.
It can be as easy
as running a tool
to see how your code performs
or writing a small benchmark
on your target platform
to figure out the best
decision to take,
which is why you need
to check out the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns
content.
Who knows what type of
performance problems
you haven't uncovered yet.
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community, as well,
for tips and advice
from other developers.
So as always, keep
calm, profile your code,
and remember perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]